[Música]
como todos sabemos él
4 de diciembre del año pasado se publicó
en el diario oficial de la federación un
decreto presidencial para fortalecer el
ejercicio del derecho de los familiares
de las víctimas del caso ayotzinapa a
conocer la verdad
este decreto crea una comisión que ha
sido llamada por los medios de
comunicación sin que haya una
rectificación ni de la oficina de la
presidencia ni de ninguna otra oficina
gubernamental ha sido llamada comisión
de la verdad
no hay ninguna parte del decreto no hay
una sola línea del decreto donde se le
denomina de esta manera donde se le
denomina comisión de la verdad la
comisión es la verdad que an
[Música]
y han trabajado en diferentes países del
mundo se han creado un conflicto armado
entre el gobierno y algún grupo que lo
combate a una dictadura y tienen por
objeto hacer una indagación sobre hechos
violatorios de derechos humanos sus
causas y sus consecuencias dice la onu
que estas comisiones deben gozar de la
más amplia facilidad para sus
investigaciones y están integradas por
gente de alta calidad moral y
profesional de alto prestigio moral y
profesional y no tener ninguna
interferencia política
la comisión que se crea en el decreto
aludido no tiene ninguna de estas
características en primer lugar no surge
después de una lucha armada
de carácter político o después de una
dictadura
en segundo lugar no tiene como objeto
hacer indagaciones sobre lo ocurrido en
un período más o menos considerable
se crea para el caso de china para que
como todos sabemos ocurrió en unas
cuantas horas la noche del 26 de
septiembre y la madrugada del 27 de
septiembre de 2014 se van a cumplir ya
cinco años en ese lugar no tiene y tome
pero más importante no tiene facultades
para hacer una indagación no tiene
facultades de investigación las
comisiones de la verdad no pueden
establecer responsabilidades
individuales pero sus investigaciones en
aportar evidencia útil
una investigación penal y en su caso
para una acusación penal esta comisión
no tiene esa facultad
en cuarto lugar esta comisión no
solamente no tiene solamente puede
decirse que no tenga interferencia
política está presidida por el
subsecretario de gobernación
y está integrada representa la
secretaria de hacienda y representantes
de la secretaría de relaciones
exteriores dudoso que sus miembros sean
de la calidad profesional se puede dice
el decreto acudir
a la comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos pero ya tuvimos la amarga
experiencia de la intervención del grupo
interdisciplinario de expertos
independientes el famoso y que no aportó
nada a la investigación y en cambio
contra todas las evidencias científicas
negó que haya habido un incendio en el
basurero de cocula no es entonces esto
una comisión de la verdad está bien por
supuesto que se fortalezca el derecho de
los familiares las víctimas a conocer la
verdad lo que pasó aquí noche triste de
dijo la cópula el caso de china para
pero para eso no hacía falta crear esta
comisión
con crítica en general
si no él personalmente algún colaborador
en las a los familiares víctimas
informados todo lo que se va avanzando y
los familiares víctimas como en
cualquier otro caso de índole penal
aportar las evidencias de que dispongan
dice el decreto
mencioné de secretaria de estado la
comisión está integrada por los
familiares de las víctimas o
representantes a quien ellos designan
como todos sabemos el artículo 2
significa
todos los mencionados si yo digo los
asistentes a la plática refiero a todos
ustedes si digo algunos asistentes no me
refiero a todos
que especificar a quienes entonces dice
que esta comisión estará integrada por
los familiares
la víctima china para la víctima del
caso
son 43 sus familiares deben ser por lo
menos 430
un representante de estos familiares
designe y sabemos que quienes han
representado a los familiares no han
actuado
en búsqueda de la verdad sino que busca
como el propio jay repito político
otra parte si se quiere conocer la
verdad estaría conatel puntualmente la
recomendación que sobre el caso hizo la
comisión nacional de los derechos
humanos esta recomendación no es fácil
conocer para empezar porque tiene
sorprende
178 páginas
pensando en un documento de dos mil 178
páginas
él dice
esta novela fantástica que es moby dick
pero una recomendación de 2.178 páginas
no es fácil de leer
pero esta recomendación
hay un elemento que reconoce el fiscal
general de la república el doctor
alejandro gertz manero indican que una
investigación muy sólida que hubo una
investigación muy profesional en busca
de la verdad y aquí quiero recordar unos
versos que me encantan de antonio
machado
si ven conmigo a buscarla
esta recomendación por ejemplo dice
y de 63.000 escucharon bien
3000 restos nos resguarda 2 dice la
comisión en la procuraduría hoy diremos
fiscalía general la república
63 mil restos no recuperados
pero de cocula y río san juan
un análisis muestra al resto sindical
que por lo menos 114 serían susceptibles
de ser analizados
por el laboratorio de innsbruck que es
el laboratorio más prestigiado en la
materia identificación por vía genética
y estos
114 elementos susceptibles de ser
analizados
41 son petrosa una una petrosa
un hueso una parte
qué
esconde al oído interno 41 petrosa
significa que por lo menos ahí se pueden
identificar los cuerpos 21 personas
con enviarlos al laboratorio de
innsbruck y esperar los resultados
asombrosamente y
la fiscalía general de la república han
solicitado hasta donde la fiscalía
general de la república ha solicitado
este análisis
y análisis sería muy importante porque
revelaría que hay más restos calcinados
todos son restos calcinados de los
estudiantes normalistas de ayotzinapa
estudiantes que fueron identificados por
esos restos encontrados ahí
aunque no se identificara con esos
restos a ninguno de los estudiantes de
ayotzinapa se identificaría a otras
personas y como sabemos en el país hay
muchas fosas clandestinas hay muchos
desaparecidos y los familiares de alguna
víctima podrían saber que allí se
encontraron restos de del ser querido
entonces
no hay comisión de la verdad
y qué bueno que no haya comisión de la
verdad porque no se está investigando
aquí como en las comisiones de la verdad
hechos ocurridos durante un período de
varios años
una comisión de la verdad corre el
peligro de no buscar la verdad sino
buscar
una versión que sirva a intereses
políticos cuando se busca la verdad
obteniendo hacen que se vaya creando una
hipótesis cuando en lugar de buscarse la
verdad se busca un rédito político no
hay tal búsqueda de la verdad lo que hay
es una actitud donde en lugar de guiarse
por las pruebas seguían se van guiando
por ciertos tiempos por ciertos
intereses y no se busca por así decirlo
la verdad verdadera sino la verdad
estratégica
la procuración de justicia en méxico en
muchas ocasiones se ha corrompido con
falsas acusaciones y se ha corrompido
con encubrimientos el caso de ayotzinapa
es uno de los casos de violación de
derechos humanos más graves del presente
siglo
es un hecho de las víctimas y es un
derecho del conjunto de la sociedad
mexicana que se dé a conocer la verdad y
es un deber de la fiscalía general de la
república indagar con todos los
elementos a su alcance que sucedió esa
noche se ha dicho por ejemplo dijo
presidente de la de la
que se ha denominado comisión de la
verdad el subsecretario de derechos
humanos de gobernación ha dicho la única
verdad es que no se sabe la verdad pero
nadie ha refutado nadie
la aportación principal de la
investigación del entonces pg de los
normalistas fueron detenidos por
policías municipales y fueron entregados
a un grupo criminal esto no ha sido
refutado por nadie no lo ha refutado en
su recomendación la comisión nacional de
los derechos humanos ni nadie lo ha
refutado y este es el punto principal
del caso que pasó después que éxito con
los restos porque además cuando digo eso
con los restos quiero decir
y pronunciar cierta
cierta palabra se dice los estudiantes
desaparecidos y vamos a buscarlos como
si no se supiera ya que es lamentable
destino de estas víctimas entonces hay
un lenguaje hipócrita hay un lenguaje
que se quiere políticamente correcto
pero que de alguna manera muy importante
encubre la verdad sobre el caso se
podría hablar mucho más pero el tiempo
se me ha agotado y espero que su
paciencia no muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]